johnny cueto fresh off the injured list
and ready to face the mets tonight
taiwan walker's first pitch at city
field is coming right up and now he'll
face the powerful giants first time
he'll be facing the giants since 2017
when he was wearing a mariner's uniform
and it's on the inside corner and wade
knew it
walker takes care of wade with a
fastball for the first out of the night
fly ball shallow right and then comes
conforto to get it another two out 23rd
base tonight and he flies one out to
right field and this one should be easy
for conforto
an eight-pitch inning for taiwan walker
as he sets the giants down one two three
and johnny cueto on the mound coming
back from the injured list
right into the defense and playing the
second base position
the third baseman chris bryant throws
him out pete's got a nine-game hitting
streak going that matches the longest of
his career two hits to right field last
night
and he lines this one up the middle and
now he's got a 10-game hitting streak
longest of his career didn't wait long
first pitch right back up the middle
and he struck him out
little cutter on the outside at the
knees two down
right toward dickerson
the inning is over
maya's over three last night this is his
third game back from the injured list
and he tops one slowly cueto can't get
it bryant can't bare-handed and baez has
an infield hit his first ever hit
against cueto in 13 at bats
as dom smith didn't start the last two
games back in the lineup tonight trying
to shake an old for 17 stretch and he
lines one the other way down for a base
hit so just like that ultra 17 is gone
and the meta back to back hits to start
the second inning
they're not running
that ball is lined into center field and
caught
yes goes back to second
and where's baez
he's at third
double play
wow he saw that low line or he thought
for sure was sinking he's just going on
contact he didn't even think where yaz
was playing
yes with an easy catch two outs runner
first base so two count low stress
inning over
change up for the strikeout
that's line top the middle but right
there to play it is mcneil
played perfectly in the shift
seven up and seven down for walker his
first ground ball out
another one for mcneil this time in a
different part of the real estate he
throws out la stella
walker fields the ground ball and he's
got nine up and nine down to start his
night
title on walk looking for his first hit
as a left-hand batter
lined up the middle and taiwan walker
has a left-handed hit he was always
exclusively a right-hand batter but
about four or five starts ago he
experienced a little pain in his left
shoulder swinging right-handed adopted
the other side of the plate and now he's
got a knock
hit softly
here's one lester the first two a double
play
and just like that the inning is over
nine up and nine down for taiwan walker
he starts the second tour of the giants
order
and wade flies one out to left chance
for dom smith
[Applause]
10 up and 10 down
a little bloop
on the run by us
the catch what a play
bias had to run a mile on a ball that
did not have much air under it and makes
a magical play
bryant batting with two down and nobody
on
bryant hits a high drive left center
field this one is
gone and off the facade of the second
level
the first hit for the giants
is chris bryant's 23rd home run of the
year
and that was a mammoth home run
one-nothing giants lead there goes
dickerson and it's swung and missed for
strike three so walker
strikes out crawford to end the inning
after bryant's home run gives the giants
the lead one nothing in the fourth 3-2
to vr
and that's inside ball four
that's lined up the middle and taiwan's
got another hit
maybe just stick with his left hand
hitting thing
two for two he had one hit all season
coming into the night
and now a couple of left hand strokes
two base hits up the middle two for two
and brannon takes inside and that loads
them up for alonso three two
and he grounded down to third bryant
will throw to
first home
bryant had a routine play and made a
terrible throw vr scores and the mets
tie the game so bases loaded two down
and a pop-up on the very first pitch
jose alvarez does his job again
now conforto takes one of the vacant
space and he's got to base it
with the full shift on conforto hits it
solidly the other way
and the mets have the leadoff man on in
the sixth so now the go-ahead running
scoring position with one out for dom
smith
gets a breaking ball and drills it
toward the right field corner and
that'll get the mets the lead
then forto comes around to score dom
pulls in at second base with an rbi
double lance 2-1 new york
vr hits it up the middle crawford dives
and he will throw to third no chance he
knew vr is too fast that keeps that from
going into the outfield and probably
keeps the mets
from scoring the third run for now
on the ground to first belt that's one
crawford back to first watson
finds the bag double play
and that one off the glove and then off
the foot
a vr
he used to use a phrase
he kicked it well he did he did kick it
pop fly
and conforto racing in and now mcneil
and neither one can get to it
bryant safely into second base
comporter comes flying in unable to make
that play try to cover all that ground
cause taiwan walker was just pitching
beautifully and he was
he was yelling at his manager trying to
argue to stay in the game and
the mets took him out
crawford wax one down the right field
line toward the corner that's a base hit
up against the wall it rough ricochets
away from conforto coming around third
is bryant he scores dickerson's heading
home the relay and the giants have gone
ahead on one pitch from the bullpen
[Applause]
runners go and crawford as a dead duck
at third base wow a 3-2 to casalli and
he struck him out with a changeup
stella pops what up in the shallow left
long run in for dom he'll get there and
that retires the side
nimbo finds the hole and he's got a base
hit
so nimo nimo's on base for the second
time tonight a walk his last time up and
now a hard single to right to get the
tying run on base
right back
to leon there's one
back to first two a double play
that's the fifth double play turned by
the giants
in seven innings
[Music]
shallow right center
and conforto can't quite get to it ruff
is going to keep on going
and into second with a double
that's hit hard caught by baez throw the
second double play
[Applause]
and that's lifted out to center easy for
nimmo who's had a busy night that
retires the side two strikes to count
right there outside corners struck him
out looking wow
why not nobody on
and that's all for conforto
and he lunges for that slider
belt and casale it is casali
giants holding a three to two lead and
jake mcgee will try and make that enough
as he is looking for his 29th save of
the year
high fastball puts him away
[Applause]
and vr pops one up behind first belt
back into foul ground
[Applause]
and vr cracks one toward the middle for
a base hit
so given a second try vr comes through
with a base hit and the mets have the
tying run aboard
and drury pops it up
medium depth center field
slater making the call and so is
dickerson added threats i don't believe
it
and this bizarre night of baseball
continues
brandon belt the infield fly rule is in
effect and leandora was out
and he walked up to load the bases and
alonso will be coming up
drury the possible winning run at second
the flare and right to la stella
and the ball game is over
jake mcgee bailed him out and
in a way that was the fifth out of the
inning
jake mcgee shrugged it all off and saved
the ball game